[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es mal wieder ein richtig schnelles und einfaches,
superleckeres und gesundes Rezept.
Ich werde eine Couscous-Pfanne mit Gemüse machen.
Ihr könnt sie
– also sie ist vegetarisch.
Ihr könnt sie gerne auch vegan zubereiten.
Im Prinzip habe ich nur am Ende
so ein bisschen Nomadenkäse, den ich drüber streue.
Ansonsten wäre sogar die Pfanne komplett vegan,
supereinfach und wirklich innerhalb von nur
15 Minuten fertig,
15 bis 20 Minuten.
Ich zeige euch mal die Zutaten.
Ihr könnt natürlich auch abwandeln und variieren,
vor allem mit den Gemüsesorten,
was ihr gerade da habt.
Ob ihr Champignons oder Auberginen nehmt,
nehmt, was euch schmeckt und was ihr da habt.
Und ansonsten, legt direkt los.
Also ich brauche dafür
drei Esslöffel Olivenöl,
eine Knoblauchzehe,
drei Zucchini,
zwei rote Paprika,
zwei Karotten,
etwas Gemüsebrühe,
Couscous,
Tomaten,
eine rote Zwiebel,
zwei Frühlingszwiebeln
und Petersilie.
Hier habe ich noch Salz, Pfeffer und getrocknete Minze
und etwas Nomadenkäse.
Gut.
Hilfst du mir?
Kannst du mir helfen?
Okay.
Komm mal weiter her.
Hauptsache, erst mal wird gegessen.
Gut. Was kann ich dir geben
zum Schneiden?
Guck mal.
Wir vierteln die Tomaten.
Und zwar nimmst du das,
machst aber nicht die Hände rein, weil da sind Messer drin.
Okay?
Und jetzt kannst du die Tomate reinlegen.
Oh, warte mal. Erst mal die Ärmelchen hoch.
Hast du da so ein Daumending gemacht?
Ach Ela, du coole Nuss.
So.
Bist du ein kleines Lämmchen,
was Petersilie isst?
Okay.
Guck mal, Tomate reinlegen.
Und hier, das kommt jetzt hier rein
und dann einfach so drücken.
Drück mal.
Einmal feste.
Ja!
Und jetzt hast du die Tomate geschnitten,
ohne deine Hand zu schneiden.
Kannst du das alleine?
Und letzte.
Super!
>> ELA: Die kleine kann man nicht machen.
Die ist viel zu klein.
>> SALLY: Die kommt...
Guck mal. Wenn du eine kleine Tomate hast,
machst du es einfach so.
Und dann kannst du die auch machen.
Jetzt noch mal drücken.
Ui.
Perfekt! Vielen Dank!
Danke schön.
Dann mache ich hier kurz weiter, okay?
Tamam?
Okay.
Ich kann jetzt zuerst einmal
das Olivenöl in meiner Pfanne erhitzen.
Denn es geht jetzt direkt schon mit dem Kochen los.
Nehmt jetzt auch eine schöne große Pfanne,
wo wirklich auch das gesamte Gericht reinpasst.
Dann kann ich die Knoblauchzehe fein hacken.
Ihr könnt sie auch fein reiben
oder pressen.
Ela, wo gehst du hin?
Mit der ganzen Petersilie?
>> ELA: Da hat es noch genug Petersilie.
>> SALLY: Isst du die jetzt?
Du bist ja cool!
>> ELA: Mama, guck. Da sind noch ein paar.
>> SALLY: Ah okay.
Hast du mir noch ein bisschen was übrig gelassen, ja?
Okay.
>> ELA: Tschüss, Mama.
>> SALLY: Die Knoblauchzehe kann ich
jetzt hier schon mal anbraten.
Die Ela
wollte mir helfen, hat die Tomaten geschnitten,
die Petersilie geklaut und ist wieder gegangen.
Die erinnert mich einfach an Murat.
Ela lebt, um zu essen.
Ja, ist echt so.
Ich habe schon ganz viele Videos gemacht,
in denen ich einfach gefilmt habe, wie Ela isst.
Wenn sie isst, da kennt sie auch nichts.
Gut.
Das lasse ich jetzt hier bei mittelhoher Hitze
anbraten
und kümmere mich um die Zucchini.
Die Zucchini wird jetzt eher grob gewürfelt.
Ich will nämlich, dass sie schön bissfest bleibt.
Zuerst mal halbieren,
vierteln
und dann etwa so 2 cm dick abschneiden.
[Musik]
Den Herd stelle ich jetzt doch noch mal kurz runter.
Denn der ist schneller, als ich es bin.
[Musik]
Die Paprika habe ich jetzt auch grob geschnitten.
Jetzt kann ich noch
die Karotten schälen
und auch einfach in Scheiben schneiden.
Die jetzt so in 5 mm Scheiben.
[Musik]
Und jetzt geht es ans Anbraten.
Ich gebe jetzt erst die Karotten rein,
weil die einfach am längsten brauchen,
aber, wie gesagt, hier möchte ich alles
schön bissfest haben,
und brate die jetzt etwa ein, zwei Minuten an.
Was kann ich noch tun?
Ich kann jetzt noch die Zwiebel kurz schneiden
in Halbringe.
[Musik]
>> ELA: Papa denkt, das wären Blumen.
>> SALLY: Echt?
Ja, du weißt doch, der Papa, der...
Der Papa, der kauft mir doch nie Blumen.
Von dem kriege ich doch immer nur Petersilie.
>> ELA: Ich pflücke dir ein paar Blumen.
>> SALLY: Ja?
Echt?
Oh!
Danke, Schatz!
>> ELA: Ich lasse das kurz hier.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Die Frühlingszwiebel schneide ich jetzt hier auch noch.
Hier kommt jetzt die Zucchini mit rein.
Auch ein bisschen mit anbraten.
Ich glaube so langsam,
mein Topf ist
zu klein.
Nicht schlimm.
Ich wollte eigentlich nicht so viel machen und dann
wurde es wieder so viel.
Die Paprika kommt jetzt auch rein.
Jetzt gebe ich mal den Deckel drauf,
dass es wirklich so drei, vier Minuten lang schmoren kann.
Ja.
Und solange kann ich jetzt nur warten.
Denn alles andere ist schon vorbereitet.
Oh, die Petersilie, die hacke ich noch.
Die, die Ela übrig gelassen hat.
[Musik]
>> ELA: Hier!
>> SALLY: Oh, Schatz, hast du das für mich gepflückt?
>> ELA: Papa hat sie gepflückt und ich wollte...
Und Papa hat sie mir gegeben, damit ich rasen kann.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Wie schön!
Jetzt iss mal schön deine Petersilie auf.
Dein Mund ist nämlich schon ganz grün.
Danke!
Ich mache das gleich in ein Teeglas, okay?
Und dann stelle ich es hier ins Bild.
Danke, mein Schatz!
Oh, guck mal, wie schön!
Das macht jetzt unsere Küche viel, viel schöner, gell?
>> ELA: Dann kommen alle zu uns.
Guck mal! Ein Blütenblatt.
>> SALLY: Ein Blütenblatt. Ja.
Voll schön!
Danke!
>> ELA: Daraus kann ich ein Muster machen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Okay. Das Gemüse sieht perfekt aus.
Allerdings habe ich ein bisschen zu großzügig gerechnet.
Ich nehme jetzt echt die Hälfte raus,
ich schreibe es euch auch etwas korrigiert auf den Blog
beziehungsweise in die App
und nehme das einfach für morgen.
Da kann ich morgen noch was daraus machen.
So.
Denn für die Couscousmenge reicht auch
diese Menge hier jetzt in der Pfanne.
Okay.
Wenn das Gemüse angebraten ist,
dann mit Gemüsebrühe ablöschen.
Kurz köcheln lassen.
Dann die Gewürze dazu geben,
also Minze.
Bei Salz müsst ihr ein bisschen aufpassen.
Je nachdem, wie würzig schon die Gemüsebrühe ist,
einfach mal individuell
anpassen und abschmecken.
Und dann könnt ihr jetzt nämlich schon
den Couscous dazu geben.
Der braucht ja nicht so lange Ziehzeit
und auch keine Kochzeit.
Schön alles durchrühren.
Als Kind habe ich immer total gern Couscous gegessen.
Meine Mama hat dann,
hat den gekocht
und hat dann immer mit Joghurt drauf.
Also das war so unser Lieblingskinderessen.
Okay.
Und jetzt kann ich hier
den Deckel nämlich einfach darauf geben.
Die Hitze auf
1 runter stellen.
Und dann braucht es jetzt etwa nur noch fünf Minuten ziehen
und ich bin fertig.
In der Zeit räume ich hier auf.
Die restlichen Zutaten kommen dann nämlich
einfach kurz vor dem Verzehr mit dazu.
Ich hole schon mal Teller zum Probieren.
Ta-daa!
Und jetzt kommt hier noch
das übrige Gemüse rein,
also erst mal Petersilie.
Die Zwiebeln,
die gebe ich jetzt roh mit rein.
Denn ich finde, das passt so wirklich perfekt,
weil es rote Zwiebeln einfach sind.
Dann Frühlingszwiebeln
und Elas geviertelte Tomaten.
Jetzt schön alles durchrühren,
den Couscous ein bisschen lockern.
Und dann lasse ich heute drei starke Männer probieren.
Ta-ta-daa!
Das war euer Stichwort!
Nimmst du Chili mit?
>> MURAT: Drei starke Männer?
Eigentlich ist es nur einer,
weil es sind zwei Veganer dabei.
>> SALLY: Hallo?!
>> MURAT: Darf ich...
>> SALLY: Kommt, Männer. Kommt.
>> MURAT: Also, wie gesagt, drei... Ein Mann...
>> SALLY: Volkan, bringst du Chili mit?
>> MURAT: Ein Mann, zwei Veganer.
So.
>> SALLY: Hör auf, die Veganer zu haten!
>> MURAT: Was ist los, Ladys?
>> DENNIS: Ja, ich möchte mal mit den Vorurteilen hier
>> SALLY: aufräumen,
>> DENNIS: dass Veganer immer nur
mit Pflanzen zu tun hätten oder so.
>> VOLKAN: Einen Löffel, oder?
>> SALLY: Nee. Ich mache es lieber bei euch drauf.
Okay.
>> MURAT: Das ist jetzt 100% vegan?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Aber bei dir werde ich noch Käse mit reingeben.
>> MURAT: Ja, bitte mach bei mir ein bisschen Käse
noch rein.
>> SALLY: Ich darf euch leider nur
so ein kleines Schälchen geben.
Sarah muss noch fotografieren.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> VOLKAN: Ah, okay.
Ja.
Aber ihr kriegt dann danach. Okay?
Kriegt ihr noch mehr.
Und das war jetzt ein Rezept,
das war innerhalb von
15 bis 20 Minuten fertig.
>> MURAT: Ihr müsst halt schnell essen,
weil sonst welkt es.
>> DENNIS: Mmh! Also riechen tut es schon mal sehr gut.
>> SALLY: Der ist so blöd!
>> MURAT: So.
Hier, Dennis, ess, bevor es...
>> SALLY: Nehmt noch Chili.
Vielleicht muss ich bei euch ein bisschen nachwürzen,
weil ich habe es jetzt nicht so stark gewürzt,
>> DENNIS: Mmh!
>> SALLY: damit...
Der Käse, der kommt jetzt hier bei dir noch drauf.
Wir haben eine Fliege hier.
Ich mache das für dich.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> VOLKAN: Für dich auch Chili?
>> SALLY: Ja. Murat auch Chili.
Dem starken Mann hier.
>> MURAT: Nein, lass. Bei mir nicht.
>> SALLY: Doch, doch, doch! Gib ihm drauf.
>> MURAT: Nur ein bisschen.
Stopp! He! Das ist zu viel!
So.
>> SALLY: Du hast gesagt "starker Mann".
Komm, probiert mal.
Superschnell, ganz einfach und gesund.
>> DENNIS: Ich freue mich schon auf später.
>> VOLKAN: Lecker!
>> SALLY: Ja, nicht?
Und ich habe alles schön bissfest gelassen,
weil ihr alle noch jung seid
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: und noch kauen könnt.
Mh?
>> MURAT: Hm.
Mmh!
>> VOLKAN: Sehr frisch.
>> SALLY: Kann man schon öfter mal machen, gell?
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Einfach so abends, so nach Feierabend.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Oder auch mal zum Fastenbrechen, Iftar.
>> MURAT: Hat auch irgendwas Asiatisch. Kann das sein?
>> DENNIS: Mhm.
>> MURAT: Findest du nicht?
>> SALLY: Koriander hätte man noch reinmachen können.
Ja, so marokkanisch.
>> VOLKAN: Marokkanisch.
>> DENNIS: Schmeckt einfach gut.
Nach Erholung, nach Urlaub so.
Ja, Urlaub.
Kann ich Urlaub haben?
Ich würde gerne Urlaub machen.
>> MURAT: Was?
>> DENNIS: Ich würde gerne Urlaub machen.
>> SALLY: Hä?
Wer bei uns arbeitet hat doch jeden Tag Urlaub.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> DENNIS: Ja, stimmt.
>> MURAT: Aber ehrlich, he.
Mmh!
Voll cool!
>> DENNIS: Sehr lecker!
>> SALLY: Sag bloß, dir schmeckt es?
>> MURAT: Und ich denke auch, dass
Zutaten, die nicht gekocht sind,
natürlich viel vitaminreicher sind.
>> SALLY: Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Und wie gesagt, könnt ihr Gemüsesorten nehmen,
die ihr gerade da habt,
die ihr mögt.
Tauscht sie gerne aus.
Ich finde, das ist ein cooles Grundrezept,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: was jeder mal zubereiten kann.
>> MURAT: Und Veganer, ihr braucht ja...
>> DENNIS: Und leicht.
>> MURAT: Ihr braucht ja viele Vitamine, gell?
Dass ihr überlebt.
>> DENNIS: Sehr leicht. Also das ist...
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> DENNIS: Du bist trotzdem gesättigt,
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> DENNIS: aber du hast nicht dieses Füllegefühl.
Das ist halt das Tolle.
Deswegen mag ich Couscous auch sehr gerne.
>> SALLY: Ich liebe Couscous!
>> VOLKAN: Ich auch.
>> SALLY: Auch so Couscous mit Mango-Curry.
>> DENNIS: Außerdem haben wir so tolle Zutaten.
>> SALLY: So richtig cool.
Ja.
Also das Rezept gibt es in meiner App.
Ich hole gleich noch Ela mit dazu.
Vielleicht isst sie mit oder sie isst nur Petersilie.
Und dann könnt ihr es gerne nachkochen
und ein Foto hochladen.
Wir schauen es uns gerne an.
Okay.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
>> MURAT: Und dann schön ein 300 Gramm Dry Aged
wäre richtig [Pfiff].
>> SALLY: Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
>> VOLKAN: Tschau!
>> SALLY: Man kann das übrigens auch kalt essen als Salat.
>> VOLKAN: Ja.
>> SALLY: Da kann man es auch so als Grillbeilage
kann man es auch ganz cool machen.
Also man hat da echt verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
>> MURAT: Schön ein Entrecôte
dazu.
Aua!
Okay.
Macht es gut!
>> VOLKAN: Tschau!
>> MURAT: Macht es besser!
>> DENNIS: Tschau!
>> VOLKAN: Tschau!
>> SALLY: Macht es vegetarisch.
>> MURAT: Geht ihr links. Dann gehe ich rechts.
So.
>> SALLY: Ach, komm. Ich halte zu dir.
[Musik]